one of the problems I think that young
people do face now is that there isn't
such an obvious sort of cultural pathway
laid out for them in terms of this is
what you do at particular times this is
how you grow up like it's all it's kind
of all to play for as as Jean says you
know adolesence is increasingly extended
um people are having getting married and
having children much later in life that
these kind of adult Milestones are not
being um presented in the way that they
once um would have been and and what
we're mostly seeing you know maybe some
people are really enjoying that freedom
really enjoying the um the option to
design their own life course but
actually I think most people find a lot
of um comfort and reassurance in being
um slightly more fashioned about these
things